THEN GET BACK TO YOU SOON AS WE
CAN.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
THANKS.
MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS MADE
CONCERNING PRESIDENTIAL ADVISOR
AND SON-IN-LAW JARED KUSHNER.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS IN
WASHINGTON TO TELL US.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
FOX NEWS CONFIRMED THROUGH
MULTIPLE SOURCES OF THE
PRESIDENT SON-IN-LAW JARED
KUSHNER RECENTLY RECEIVED HIS
FULL SECURITY CLEARANCE.
LATE TODAY HIS LAWYER SAINT, HE'
LATE TODAY HIS LAWYER SAINT, HES
CLEARANCE WAS HANDLED BY THE
BOOK.
>> HAPPENED IN THE NORMAL
COURSE.
HAPPENED THE WAY IT HAPPENS FOR
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
GOES TO INITIALLY THE BUREAU.
AS A BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION.
IT GETS THROUGH VARIOUS AGENCIES
AND GETS TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THERE IS A SPECIAL OFFICE THAT
DOES SECURITY MEASURES.
THEY ARE ALL CAREER PEOPLE.
>> KUSHNER HAD BEEN WORKING OFF
AN INTERIM SECURITY CLEARANCE AS
HE PURSUED FOREIGN POLICY ISSUES
ON BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT.
IN FEBRUARY THE INTERIM
CLEARANCE WAS DOWNGRADED AFTER
CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY ISSUED
NEW RULES, AND THE SECURITY
INVESTIGATION HAD NOT BEEN
COMPLETED.
WITH THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION
LOOMING, THE CLEARANCE BECAME A
MAJOR MEDIA STORY.
>> IS JARED KUSHNER BECOMING A
DISTRACTION?
>> JAROD IS A VALUED MEMBER OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND HE'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
THE WORK THAT HE HAS BEEN DOING.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE PUSHING
FORWARD.
>> THE DECISION WAS DESCRIBED AS
SIGNIFICANT GIVING THE MUELLER
PROBE BECAUSE THE MATTER WOULD
HAVE BEEN REVIEWED AND APPROVED
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE
FBI.
THE OFFICIAL SAID ACCESS TO
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS NO MATTER
WHAT LEVEL OF CLEARANCE WOULD
ONLY HAPPEN IF THERE WERE NO